some unexplained
reason
the new york city district attorney
refuses to drop murder charges against
bodega the bodega worker who defended
himself as you can see in this video
against a career criminal the video is
clear as day you've seen you of course
jose alba's minding his own business
working the counter to harlem bodega
career criminal austin simon got angry
over a bag of chips came around the
counter clearly
named alba and then alba defended
himself with a knife it's black letter
law as they say black letter
self-defense plain as day okay so to
give you guys the fuller details i'm
going to show you guys the footage of
the actual thing because you can find it
online if you really want to see it use
a couple stills here and there
essentially a young woman comes into the
bodega where jose albert i think his
name
um basically tells her like yeah if you
want to buy this just pay and she says
what can i just pay on credit he's like
no we don't do that you got to pay cash
and she goes on to say well my daddy's
own a bodega and he used to just hand
things to people if they needed it and
they pay him back on credit he's like
well listen i'm not your dad and i run
the business i need your money because
i'm not i see you again
can't risk it they have an argument then
her boyfriend comes in okay and her
boyfriend's like yo why don't you just
give her the photo she said i'm not
giving her nothing the boyfriend goes
behind the counter okay to this old 61
year old man and shoves him into the
wall and starts looming over him okay
this is exactly how it goes down
the owner right of the bodega the 61
year old grabs a knife as he's trying to
move past him gets a couple stabs in and
starts to move away
the man who's a carel criminal he's got
a lot of rapture in regards to committed
crimes like these
uh ends up succumbing to his injuries
and he dies the d.a charges jose
with second-degree murder
even though all this is caught on video
now there's been a lot of outrage a lot
of people feel some type of way
right
and they've been talking to the d.a to
get him to drop these charges
another detail that came out afterwards
i thought was really interesting is that
the girlfriend
she ended up pulling out a knife as well
out of her purse and she stabbed the
bodega owner in the arm
creating lacerations and she hasn't been
charged with anything
so
that's the gist of this whole thing
what are your thoughts free about by
jose i actually have nothing to do with
the fact that he's a career criminal
i don't care that he's a career criminal
he would have a perfect
record
and would have died there he still
i still wouldn't charge him
someone with a perfect record would have
done the same thing
and end up dying to me that's just
something that happened
you went it you went for baggage you
went around the counter
you wilding you went around the counter
to shove something for a bag of chips
now you're gonna tell me i hear some
people in the comments yeah but some
people are hungry some people are hungry
a bag of chips ain't gonna do nothing
for your hunger i don't know when i see
stuff like this i'm just like he's very
fortunate the person didn't pull out a
weapon and hit him first with it but
it's like yeah it's dangerous out here
and if you think i'm being hyperbolic go
on the new york post there's a bunch of
videos that you can watch of people
getting shot up in bodegas yeah recent
too you can watch the whole and it's not
because you're hungry and poverty is the
thing that you have to go around your
way to menace people to get what you get
if you get stabbed trying to get a prop
someone's property or you get killed
trying to get someone's property
and someone's trying to defend them
they're trying to defend defend
themselves and you end up dying to me
it's just something that happens it's
just something that happens
move on he defend not it's not even
about his property it's not like the guy
was at the door and he threw a knife at
him or he ran after him with a knife
while the person was exiting
now you would be you'd be doing the most
if i'm in my little space my cubicle
you go around your way to go around that
count i don't know what you're gonna do
you shove me and you go around me i'm
gonna grab something and defend myself a
hundred it's a it's a question of it's
either you or me and i gotta choose me
i gotta choose me
i'ma choose me every [ __ ] time
[Laughter]
i gotta choose me
and if you end up dying it is what it is
so that's [ __ ] up that yeah he's been
charging [ __ ]
on cam and stuff like that sometimes i'm
like is it because i don't know what
camera like i don't know what the law is
that i think this thing is crazy
what's on your mind i know you said i
choose me i choose me you know i choose
me
the weirdest remix of pokemon i've ever
heard
or
or pikachu i choose me
i'm back in the ball [ __ ] stop at you
i'll choose me
i'm not gonna lie you gotta say i choose
me i choose me and all i heard was kevin
samuels just from above looking down
like
that's why these [ __ ] are
single ma'am man recipes kevin
i choose me just sounds like something a
lot of the women who call into kevin
trump would say
hold up hold up my bad
my bad
some folks would say well listen
you know he pushed the guy therefore
even before he ever pushed him if you go
behind the counter and you standing
bro to me your life is forfeit to some
degree i'd have been fine if he pulled
out the knife and the moment he saw any
weird movement stabbed let me tell you
why
you can't just sit there and wait
for someone to pull out whatever they
got on them or for someone to finish
whatever they do before you defend
yourself
you've already told me that you don't
give a [ __ ] about my safety and that you
are trying to threaten me and come at me
with violence when you've come around
the counter and you're hovering over me
like you are so close there's no way for
me to defend myself efficiently
before you get to do anything in a world
with guns knives all kinds of crazy
weapons i can't afford to go second
now fortunately for the bodega owner the
man put his hands on him physically but
who knows what else he had on who else
knows what he would have pulled out on
him are you going to wait to find out
i'm not going to sit there and wait it's
cool oh you'll be on the counter now
let's see what you got
nah no
to me when i watch something like this
happen
it's it it blows my mind anybody's like
why do you have to stab him seven times
have you ever had adrenaline pumping
through you when you are terrified for
your life right and someone just put
their hands on you and threatened to do
more and they're still going after you
you're not thinking like all right once
let me check on this but you're not
doing that yeah and i'm convinced that
people who say that [ __ ] have never been
in those kind of situations where you
you literally can't think everything's
reflexes you're breathing heavily your
body's tense
it's insane that's why sometimes people
get blasted they'll get shot
and they won't even feel it until the
adrenaline fades and then they pass out
because you're in such a state of shock
so me i watch this i'm like this is
clear-cut self-defense now this person
has their life upside down they're
spending time in jail until they get
bail they have these charges looming
over them they got the news and
everything all over them it's like
brother i was just trying to do my work
do my job this person came after me and
you're looking at me like i'm the
criminal how come you haven't arrested
the woman either
who took down a knife and also stabbed
him these people basically jumped this
guy
and the woman gets to walk scot-free
over a bag of chips
bruh and the boyfriend like imagine how
much of a loser you have to be to die
over a deadbeat woman who would let you
do that [ __ ] over a bag of chips like
dudes will do the dumbest [ __ ] for women
that's crazy yeah you didn't give her
the bag of chips
you won't die
for that for a bag of chips good
riddance
good riddance
you're gonna die for that you're gonna
throw somebody else for that
get the [ __ ] out of here man
so darwin the word
evolution the fact that he got charged
like this is what i'm saying like with
crime on the rise and people being like
justifiably in some places like worried
about their own safety we're doing all
this stuff to take away people's weapons
or anything that they might have while
people who are going to threaten you or
are going to put you in danger have
access to everything it's like thank god
the man had a knife there
thank god
because you think a 61 year old man is
going to be able to beat a 31 year old
on most days probably not probably not
yeah anything else
let's see what you guys think in the
comments